yeah hello welcome to this broadcast is
this actually working i hope it does so
how are you all of you here in the
twitch chat room on that Monday hmm
afternoon evening can be can be many
things so as grand masti em Olinsky
likes to say um what does he say happy
time of day to you my chest friends or
something like that okay right here in
Germany we have ten in the evening so
it's getting um getting dark young okay
give me a short confirmation please in
the chat that I'm like I really like to
do that to make sure about that before
i'm actually starting with the game so
um yeah hello good evening i hope i am
live give me quick confirmation I had
this more than once that has started
games and it wasn't really you're alive
in great sound ok cool so let's get
going there I'm starting with five
minutes Chester get started with a five
minute game Oh someone from northern
Canada huh it would be like Oh afternoon
again huh so yeah people have good
weather we have really good weather at
the moment in Germany someone requests
three minute madness I can try I did
this three minute madness videos
recently we were quite popular playing
and in the three-minute pool and um yeah
really throwing caution to the winds
yeah I don't get a game yeah 3 and five
minute I'm trying it's not good give me
games just give me games
huh that's kind of slow going him ah
play playing last stock that's a German
I am and Gaia no of course it's um he's
living just a few miles away from me so
I'm going for Kings Indian stuff don't
really know what he's playing what line
but the guy is playing this one yeah
he's a very he's a very solid positional
player so this is no big surprise yeah
rook e8 it's not really like a mad move
but after this year you cannot do
something something something brilliant
there's a question what tactics book
would you recommend for 1800 player hum
it's not so easy to say actually there
are some very good books for higher
rated players there's something but our
God definitely I'm this exhaling at
chest calculation and this also book but
I cannot really where is it here chess
chess tactics from scratch I got that I
got that in the mail like two or three
days ago it was recommended to me but I
have not yet yet looked at it it has
gotten good good reviews let's say but
nothing that I can confirm yet so I just
don't want to parrot other guys opinions
I want to have an opinion myself so I
cannot really give you one because i did
not yet study the book ah interesting
why he why there
I mean I understand the bishop pair but
anyway then the bishop is not so useful
they only six okay let's kick him it's a
three minute game so have to be
relatively quick I don't think the
bishop a eyes of that importance here I
rather i'm glad that i have three pieces
I ok that's enough that's this idea ah
once to get the Bishop to c4 but anyway
night is good on deform yes someone says
I got the time right today yeah on
Monday some this time is pretty pretty
regular feature now I mean it's it's
relatively consistent but sometimes have
those other events like simultaneous
displays and so on ok so quality chairs
is doing a 45 with black including the
brea yeah that's not a not a bad idea
for Roberto of course let's do here if I
take here and night c2 we can take one
of seven it's a neat little trick so
maybe just move here yeah why does a bit
better here maybe with the bishop pair
but it's not it's not not a lot not very
important let's aim disadvantage what is
this here I want night age 52 f forward
be cool I have to have to check that
book of course this before five brea
whatever it's a kind of my
bread-and-butter openings but who is
doing that book you feel I don't know
can you tell me who was who's writing
that book there was a rumor that a
baroque wanted to do this but I don't
know if this really really happens they
had a 45 by mahama reen Michael Maron
but this is a somewhat outdated of
course it's a few years old okay so we
got got an endgame here where I'm
somewhat worse but I hope it's not not
the end of the world and it should it
should be still okay so Jim doing how do
I continue this if he goes look here I
go Rupe his son so maybe King up to you
seven and then 936 yeah maybe this so I
have 96 when I'm down on the not down on
the clock this is so this is important I
really have to make sure that I
understand that this is three minutes
yes it's really a different animal 25
minute answering the question while
playing three minutes asked answering
questions we're playing three miniatures
is notoriously difficult came it's not
that it's not that convenient here the
whole thing all right stupid stupid
stuff but okay it might might still be
now the time is actually also a big
issue yeah and it is it is lost but i
have 10 seconds this is even though the
more pressing business
mmm instead a win actually I don't know
that could be a draw but okay we've been
on time doesn't matter um so let's go
okay I mean I like the odd three minute
game but it's difficult to combine the
commentary the questions and and the the
whole thing it's a little bit bit much
um so um
it's fundamental chess openings outdated
hmm no it's a good overview and it's not
so much about about to concrete lines
that that book so good to good over you
and I cannot tell you what is a what is
a good book for 1600 tactics it's um
really so again I'm going for them for
the Kings Indian can we can we get in
again we get some Dutch Stonewall yep I
could do that but okay let's see what we
get in the Kings Indian first playing
the bionet here with black playing with
a 5 it says I really don't not huge
expert there but i recently saw an
interesting idea there's a question how
many blitz games to usually play daily
yeah it's very easy to say on average
this would be 3 because I've released
three games a day on my channel but I'm
not playing exactly three games a day
because i usually am play sessions and
yeah like a couple of hours in a row and
them go from there and therefore it's
difficult to say it's not like a daily
routine to play some some blitz games
okay bishop evade and no it looks funky
but my idea is to play c5 if he allows
me to do that so aha interesting which
would them
I still wonder if I can play c5 takes
Knight takes bishop t6 mm-hmm it's
probably playable but I don't know how
good it is i also have night h5 let's do
that I mean night FY the queen is not
really great on d3 so I can still get
this idea n + f5 is this is this stupid
or not he has Knight to g5 ha it's
definitely true Bishop age three maybe I
wonder yeah F 595 looks a bit weird but
anyway it's interesting Knight f6 I mean
night on b5 is kind of off side
interesting it's the burn variation in
the French defense okay yep it is very
much ok just as the ruins Stein
variation there's nothing really nothing
great for white damn the burn variation
is actually a bit better compared to the
Rubenstein and the Rubenstein it's very
ok so let's see can I get in Bishop h6
let's activate that Bishop there's a
question what do I think about chess
players switching their their the
Federation's yeah switching their
nationalities um yeah what do I think
it's not so easy to the same I I do
understand the idea I mean in many cases
it's a good financial decision I guess
to just switch but I wonder if the
overall practice is some
is this helpful for chess I mean that is
it's possible yeah I don't that
something that it's not clear to me this
is a good idea but I understand the
players there are financial reasons they
have to make a living so I guess that
while playing for the u.s. probably
plays better than playing for Italy
inkay in one case so what what is this I
cannot take here on on on a five so i
probably have to move up beard it's kind
of kind of not great I really have to
get something going here it looks it
looks tricky it looks tricky yeah it's
not so clear what what what what happens
within I teach this case because he he
has already said that this is not clear
that he is actually switching
Federation's and it also not not cleared
or two to what he will switch there were
rumors about about Azerbaijan but it
wasn't confirmed that bloody c7 porn
hmm not good at all my route b7 looks
terrible it really looks terrible you
can still take them okay I need some
counterplay him I need some kinda plan
may be here for for Bishop e3 or
something it's probably just not good at
all but anyway what can you do he can
take c7 not so easily so he had to play
this move that's interesting at least
can I somehow get some play here rook f8
maybe so well anyway let's do that I can
take then and maybe invade somehow ok
let's take Queen takes Bishop e3 is at
least interesting and Knight takes I
wonder can I do something here a queen
of aid and something
Queen f8 Bishop takes bishop age three
yards of this kind of thing it's losing
but anyway I have to claim what went
wrong in this game it's not quite clear
to me oops why is he doing that because
I'm not threatening anything is that the
reason
her okay this is the only thing that
might give give me some idea but there's
still no no meat or something coming my
rook is not playing at all hmm there's
simply simply nothing happening here he
won't allow this rookie Wade okay that
was bad any kind of trick that I have
not really am this for work f seven but
he can [ __ ] and check me rook a seven
or something it's it's so easy and i
only have six seconds ah oops mm-hmm
it's still there's still no threat
that's the real issue there's still no
thread
can I get in some kind of idea and now
I'm blundering into the race not seeing
it even anyway this is this is lost here
come on let's resign that game okay
let's let's look at some questions there
um so there I comes I want to get to
some questions and then then try to do a
little bit concentrate a bit more on the
games okay there are a couple of
questions do you think that people are
born with a set limit on how the good
that can get a chest to put another way
if you quit your job and devoted
yourself to chest 24-7 could and i am
like you become world class mmm no I
don't think so I mean now I am like me I
mean I certainly couldn't maybe others
have more potential but it's difficult
to do I think there's a set limit but
it's not quite clear what that limit is
I don't think it it is it is dead low I
think maybe like 1900 2000 it's
difficult everybody can approve I think
um okay if you play the English as wide
and the French was for is they're not
natural opening were this deform I'm
he's the guy says he plays the Dutch but
it fields of a different style hmm poor
difficult it seems that you'd like
closed positions so um the Dutch
Stonewall it's pretty not a bad idea the
Queens gambit declined is also quite
natural okay so what do we have
some others what approach would you
recommend to teach children better chess
once they know the moves hmm there are
many ideas that you can do I don't
personally my own experience I am a
chess teacher but they usually teach
adults or somewhat let's say on orchids
that they'd already have a certain level
of play important is that that they
really have fun yeah while doing things
so just going for ya like like tough
work with little kids doesn't have this
should have fun who sighs real player
that you have faced in a tournament I'm
getting a new game now the highest rated
player that I have faced in the
tournament hmm i don't think i played a
2700 rated player while they were 2700 i
played people who had that kind of level
at one point but but not when i was
playing them i played like a couple of
years ago played a very strong iranian
GM crevo rush coo he's like 2690 or
something um made a draw that was very
nice um nette played many people who had
very high ratings at some other point in
their career mikhail gurevich for
example or euro and pickets the the
dutch top GM he's retired nowadays
um okay so and western let's play a game
yantai want to look at this game a
little bit I want to get a win in yeah
the first games weren't really
successful and I don't like to lose that
much so maybe I can get a game in here
where I'm concentrating a little bit
more on the moves and then I'm going to
do a couple of a couple of more
questions there the question about this
term and I'm tournament i'm playing in
in poland in rush love is it easy to get
in and be a spectator i don't think so
for open tournaments anybody can watch
it some it's no problem whatsoever so
when it should be free for everyone to I
mean everybody can participate you have
to pay an entry fee of course but it's a
it's noah no limit in any other any
other way okay i have to admit that i
forgot this line and looked at this only
recently hmm Bishop f4 or not Bishop f4
Bishop geez I really forgot it now
that's not good this guy seems to know
this this whole thing it's a tricky one
not Queenie tool
I really have forgotten the opening hip
it's been a while since I looked at that
yeah I have a bad structure but good
active pieces one ideas to play
sometimes you see five yeah like here
for example um I really have to do this
c5 Bishop takes Bishop g5 Queen takes 93
this leads to an interesting position
yeah let's do this I'm getting some good
compensation here I think for my
material I can take on g5 actually this
is a good alternative huh why not and
now Bishop age 6 looks good I just
wonder if I have something better I
could play 95 again why not this is a
good square and maybe like rook g one g
for h1 is this kind of thing makes a
difficult also film to develop so that
looks like a good move episode bishop
here or not yeah why not Queen g4 has a
pretty good move or a pretty good idea
he's got Bishop f6 though coming ok so
maybe you look he is still for up to
four if he goes Bishop f6 I can go at
four on Nyjah form now chief was also
interesting ok
oh the other questions yep I'm going to
answer them later or try to so um he
ain't f5 wow that looks like a very
weakening move back to f4 would threaten
a couple of nice discoveries might be
might be a good idea I can also switch
my attention to other things here like
the six-point important is I shouldn't
get into a huge time time pressure let's
be quick then and ask him about this
okay i thot 97 is good let's do that
come on not to think okay you can
actually move the rock you can actually
just move the rook mmm that's true we
should be five still pretty good but I
don't know if it is so convincing anyway
I have to play I'm spending too long
here my timing is a bit of I'm not I
haven't played any blitz games that's
the last couple of days so bit rusty
here so here I can take on g7 if I want
and then he's six but is it doing that
much not clear or take here maybe this
is probably ok getting group g7 still in
and just keeping the tension there I
have h4 h5 h6 as an idea and I think I'm
going to play that next ok so he allows
me to to win a porn yeah I think I'm
doing that I'm not sure it's it's it's
not clear if it's the best continuation
but it looks pretty good I can have
endeavor in two parts actually like this
and f5
okay he resigned time it's a bit it's a
bit too much I also win their fat porn
okay so let's look at question would you
have a suggestion for a 2200 player with
a slump and improvement due to excessive
blundering coming from playing online
blitz is there a solution to this
vicious cycle and improve to have em
level um you know good idea is to then
stop with the online blitzing or just
reduce it a little bit yeah keep it to
of just a couple of games and a good
idea if you want to do to improve from a
certain level where you're stuck is to
really extensively really invest time
with analyzing your over the board
tournament games yeah take take time to
look at your games and analyze them
yourself yeah with your own head not
using an engine and then if you if you
got a coach it's easier but without the
co-chief you can take your analysis and
then compared with with the computer and
maybe you found find a good training
part and it's also good yeah and then
try to go from your games and try to
find things that are not right in your
game it's not so easy yeah but it's a
good term a good idea to do another
question how does the 2400 player
improve mmm they have already become
familiar with most concepts tactics and
mating patterns so what now yeah okay
2400 is about my level there are a
couple of things but but it is some it
depends a lot on the player your
weaknesses yeah your your your your
skill set yeah they are different for
every player and is a good a good idea
to to find your weaknesses and try to
work on then I really think that one
should try to get rid of weaknesses and
a good ideas to adjust your opening
repertoire to something that you
actually play well which is not so easy
to find
and in some cases there are other things
that you can do that are not really
related to 22 chest itself improve the
physical fitness and things like that
there's the question about a book like a
modern replacement of my system mm-hmm I
don't know if there's something like
that a very nice book on modern
strategies by John Watson yeah secrets
of Modern chess strategy and I think
there's there are two books right what
has two or three books like that they're
pretty good i haven't have them on the
shelf um okay I requested a new game i
probably didn't get how sound is the
bayonetta check at high level play in
the Kings in your defense do you mean
sound for white or black the bionet is
the main line probably of the Kings
onion and it's currently I think in a
state where it's kind of switches
between wide being slightly better and
black being equal it's it's it's a close
it's a close call but it's it's more of
an attitude thing the Kings Indian the
Kings Indian is of course a risky open
opening strategically and the bionet is
a very good way to fight that I think if
you're considered for white sure go
ahead it's one of the best lines a good
idea especially for people who want to
play the classical Kings Indian but
don't want to be a tech they're like you
get in some other lines um do you think
at some point chess 960 will surpass
chess in popularity I don't know that's
not easy to say chess strategy in action
someone gives the tile yeah that's true
by John Watson that's a really good
modern strategy book will chest 960
surpass I don't know actually and I
think it will get more popular for sure
will it surpass the classical chest
mm-hmm I don't know
and one problem with checks chest 96
years that some starting positions
really suck I mean this is just no other
way to call it they just suck and are
not fun to play at all so I'm kind of
undecided I think it is it's a good idea
this this 960 but I'm not sure that it's
it leads to interesting chess all the
time you know you avoid theory that's
true and it's a good thing because the
the current state of chess is really am
some somewhat strange at times yeah they
they really rely a lot on their opening
prevent don't don't play that many moves
over the board I really understand the
problem that people have with that but
some 960 positions are really really
stodgy yeah so I don't know it's as I
said I'm kind of I'm kind of undecided
them okay I was intending to put the
bishop one day five but this really
looks like it geotech idea let's just go
back to g3 I've giving in this rook move
for free basically okay I don't know he
wants to go with fire okay I'm going out
for that's a debatable move but I want
to prevent to c5 um there's a question
someone says that they watched some of
my old Blitz videos and how did I manage
to quit smoking yeah I don't really know
I really glad that I did but it yeah
it's um I personally I mean it's
difficult i'm not the person to give
health advice but or engine then man i
can only tell you what worked for me I
managed to quit smoking using this
electric cigarettes I am
I switched from tobacco to electric and
I quit from from electric completely at
one point with the electric one arm I
reduce them the load off of nicotine
step by step and at one point I hit zero
nicotine and from then I just stopped
but it's not the strategy that it's not
a miracle thing or whatever for other
people maybe this is not working at all
for me it worked ya doing this what
someone called vaping um but it's not
it's not something that that will work
for everybody everybody has to find
their own way of getting rid of smoking
yeah one way is to simply die yeah at
one point it will happen probably quit
probably quicker with the smoke but I
don't know just just try to try to try
your best to quit it's really helpful to
do in many ways it's better for for
helpful for your money and and for your
chest as well yeah why did I start not
not the not the most great not the best
decision ever so I'm going to try to set
up for the sacrifice on the queenside
this is the only way for something to
happen in this position and he's not
really doing anything against it aha
okay come on I'm taking them I'm taking
this and try to do something with the
pawns it's not entirely clear this is
correct but it's a way to get some
something going okay be 54 B 6 his
nights are not really great at the
moment so this is my hope he might oh
this
really that's dangerous or you see it
sacrificing I he might sacrifice b6 he
might sacrifice so I'm taking and going
for before that sets better anyway if he
plays king cakes i also have Bishop b5
check by the way that's not a bad move
actually interesting i also have B form
a bishop bisaya Bishop e7 is not doing
much
before maybe weights before mm at the
end he has Ruby aid interesting
also do this I really underside it yeah
it's quite tricky and then there's what
is this how do you think physical
fitness helps a chest we'd do anything
for your fitness minute well hmm I never
did anything for my fitness and not very
healthy in that regard but I'm trying
I'm trying trying to do regular day
regular physical exercise now but but
difficult yeah there are not many
smokers in there in the top in the top
10 Grizz shook is one of them and i
recently read that the chronic actually
started to smoke again which is a pretty
sure sign that is not super ambitious
anymore for becoming world champion if
you if you ask me if just if you start
to smoke again you're basically telling
you yeah you're basically telling that
you're not that ambitious anymore I made
a terrible mistake he actually I was
thinking Bishop a six is possible but of
course it isn't and that makes it c6
very stupid that regard okay okay maybe
this is still not that bad but hmm no
have to fight
taking e 697 coming okay let's take this
that was really stupid really stupid I
didn't asada I thought I can play Bishop
a 6 but of course I couldn't and now
he's getting this this night into the
game it was such a nice position I
already had a big advantage there but I
totally totally screwed it up like it's
relatively easily winning now
okay they've got a couple of questions
and I'm going to answer them after that
game still trying to fight you a little
bit but of course the chances are very
very very very very very low for saving
that position but you can always try as
long as you have some kind of passer you
can always try age 6 ok and the king
will help a little bit at least huh I
don't know is that so precise how I
played that my age porn is kind of
dangerous a little bit at least hmm how
is he winning this I'm not seeing it at
the moment
so was he accepting a draw then
basically i don't think i can i can win
so I'm pressing the draw button here for
a petition okay so um there are a couple
of things there thanks for
this there's a question of them I
recommended a couple of minutes ago to
do a very serious analysis of their own
games and he's responding that most of
his problems come from one move blunders
or playing too quickly okay it's
difficult you really have to look at the
games and try to see if there's a
pattern there there are many reasons why
you might move too quickly yeah like
overestimating your position or simply
yeah if you play lots of blitz chess it
can it can be a problematic of course
many things it's a bit difficult I mean
I don't want to advertise my chest
teaching too much but it's may be
helpful to really ask a coach with with
the games and so on to get a more more
complete get a more complete picture so
what do we have
there are some questions there
there are some questions about about
food I really have no advice step about
if this is Regan set the right way or
vegetarian if this is good for your
chest good for you out I don't know um I
don't really know I think I'm my strong
suspicion is that actually not not
eating too much media I think it's
probably a good thing for your health
but it's I mean really I cannot answer
that question so let's play this year
against Dark Passenger I'm playing the
bogo here interesting interesting line
as someone requested the Leningrad yeah
i can actually i should play the dutch I
should try that but ok I just routinely
put out my moves I didn't really think
about it that much how interesting
that's an interesting way can you do
this maybe but ok he might take and play
not be five huh wow I really forgot the
theory him
so yeah okay what about this position
here I'm a pawn up that's good I cannot
move my bishop on CA that's not so good
let's try to make it make it participate
in the game Kim yeah why does playing
for compensation here he's tries to
occupy the D file and so on I'm thinking
about bishops is six I know it looks
kind of funky with the pawn structure
but I really learned to appreciate that
this looks weird but it's not
necessarily that bad because I get
something in return I get some activity
on the be found so um is he going for 90
of 6 or something like that hmm might be
might be 95 I wonder if that is a move
actually maybe do that
so is there some other question that I
didn't didn't didn't get not really so I
was thinking that route before would be
good here but he has Queen d3 really
that's that's quite true hmm ok I was
thinking that this is a good move but
not very well thought out is this idea
hmm now that's not too great
Jerry that's not too right
I have a bad structure and nothing to
show for it at the moment hmm I can take
on you for play Knight c3 but I don't
know if it helps too much a stupid idea
giving up that pawn the position was
totally okay i think and now i'm sitting
there with this rotten position not good
not good at all and he's got a for
coming at the worst part it's very
simple to play oh but now it's really
really bad
night 8 for more that's not a move I
considered but it's probably not bad
poor about way that's bad what a bad
position
yeah why this is so much better he can
play basically anybody move Quincy five
or whatever
so if I move here let's do this Luke t7
Queen here MA that sucks yeah I know you
can have any way I have to do that I
have to do that hmm i wonder if that
what's the best for him I mean my
position really made it probably still
is very bad but it looked worse it
really looked even worse so let's take
this and now it can probably just take
this out on him probably I can take a to
what you can double on the seventh I
wonder this might be might be tougher
relatively speaking trading one rook is
helpful here in the defense i think i'm
not a poem one pawn down okay that's the
sexpert stuff yeah we got a troll do one
the destroyer well that's a great name
guy you win the Nobel Prize for
inventiveness there what is worse feeder
or fifa hmm that's difficult probably
fifa but it's the the the similarities
are quite stunning right yeah in many in
many ways it's it's quite comparable
yeah for example FIFA has the same
idiotic practice that every every young
and member of member Federation has got
the same amount of votes in the in the
elections yeah this is this is totally
ridiculous yeah that
that that lets say i don't know the the
Fiji Islands have the same kind of
influence in the organization as as its
Germany does in football or Russia and
chest yeah this is totally ridiculous I
don't want to diss the the Fiji Islands
he or something but you know this is
kind of idiotic so on and this is the
same in FIFA and feeder you know they
have the same stupid stupid practice
there I can go ear for now why he get
here I get here that's interesting I'm
not sure really about what he's doing
here is that is that so creative why'd I
don't know I get to you for Melissa
Scalia's counterplay really check and
here for Luke t3i might still be lost
but I'm getting more activity than I
thought I would
it's got loopsy to wear to defend this
okay yeah that's not great that they had
to trade this I'm still getting not
really counterplay check them hello okay
the f porn run buddy by now i mean i
don't know he really is record okay too
okay okay so what is actually winning at
the end you really gave me lots of lots
of play lots of play that's a question
when will you have a dual commentary
match with jerry probably never because
he never plays anybody who's vaguely
good at chess or as good as he is or
better in that case um okay no i don't
recommend correspondence chess that much
you can do that but it's mostly I'm
something that is reading out computer
evaluations of playing against computers
so I don't know what what the point of
that is who is that actually it's their
name so we got a queen's gambit
let's see yeah we got a semi slavia and
analyzing your own games that the idea
is really to try to find count themes or
patterns things that do repeat yeah do
you lose in a common way do you allow a
certain type of position that you don't
handle well those kind of things are
important while i was telling that i'm
kind of miss playing this opening i
believe again I did that I did that
earlier in a in a broadcast I had the
same thing and screwed it up night a4 I
don't really remember I don't know
so we try to try to trade the dark
squared bishop because this is the
bishop that controls the square in front
of the isolated pawn I wonder what he
should play now I mean black doesn't
have any problem here in any case but
still maybe take on b2 looks good okay
if I go bishops III is this a cross pin
or something I think it's still okay
let's do that okay I can take and play
Queen c3 my idea is to control d 4 i'm
not trying to trade everything for a
draw here or something like that okay
hmm he's a ticking g2 that's not good
castling he's going bishop age three and
g3 also looks kind of wrong because he
has bishop age three not good Bishop f1
is kind of proof huh so what am i doing
him I cannot really sacrifice that pawn
that looks really wrong but anyway I
didn't see it I didn't see an
alternative so I went for that so maybe
Knight c3 e2f for this this this can
help I miss played that opening quite
quite severely that looks that looks
really bad for me yeah you shouldn't
allow this kind of thing the bishop
invading their early on so what am i
doing now can I am play
maybe this 493 f3 king of two or
something the only thing that my
position has in its favor I mean not not
like I'm better or so but what i have
going from my position is I control d
for quite reliably that's that's a good
thing but that's the only thing i would
like to play a three and get rid of this
in this Bishop but I don't think I can
he might take on a three yuck that's
really a bad position it's remarkably
bad this thing maybe I can play it
something with g4 here trying to make
some sense out of this this wacky setup
really playing bad bad game Sam no g45
maybe each voice hanging but it's not
okay maybe this I know not a good
position that's a question why never
play the caro-kann there's no particular
reason I I think it's a good opening of
course like many mainline openings it's
totally okay just that you cannot play
anything and carol card is something
that i have tried but I don't know it's
a it's it's not exactly in my focus at
the moment but it's not a bad opening so
I get this this coordinated a little bit
and I had g4 maybe I should have played
g4 he actually Mina's queen is not
exactly well placed there yeah yeah he
prevented that now so night a for maybe
four night to be six
looks trade it would be cool
so yeah we'll look at some I will look
at some questions after this game what
is this is putting it right into the
middle of my position okay maybe get the
night over here even night to d3 is an
interesting idea for night f4 it's not a
bad position I'm just down one minute I
could have played g4 earlier that was a
lot better so over here for night f4 if
he takes Bishop takes I have the
slightly better end game so I'm okay
with that oh well he's allowing night f4
I didn't expect that uh-huh surprising
let me d 5 is hanging here it's just
hanging why am I not able to take it I
don't see it let's take the pawn and I
take age 5 and d7 and all kinds of
things so this is switching in my favor
now but I still don't have time so and
here for a very nice position yeah and
if form he can take so not this small
I'm should see for maybe
how do i get that in things I don't have
time my time management is getting to me
yeah Jaya let's cue lamb but it doesn't
threaten anything I think so well I also
didn't make much headway here how can I
actually use his wacky Queen possession
okay maybe I can trade rooks that also
would be helpful just train rooks them
rook g6 is a good idea his queen is
really in a bad spot damn it cannot go
anywhere meaningful so maybe I get this
this winning against the high rated GM
compensate for some earlier losses so
here threatening rook f6 that's not easy
at all okay I can take this now and to
check let's do that not think about it
too much this here very annoying
position I'd like to play here as rook
c8 I should click wicca play quicker
buddy it's all about the time the
position is not important anymore I have
a nice position but the problem is not
there's the problem is the time going
for a full-scale pre moves now ah he
took it that's a shabby play you just
took that I came ok I won't on time I
think the pawns promote yeah my pawns
are quicker whoo so so let's see if
there are some that there are some
questions here um there's a question
what do I think about chess.com accusing
title players of cheating publicly
without presenting evidence very tricky
very tricky thing in general and very
much in favor of banning people pretty
harshly if they cheat but
it's it's difficult I mean the the the
evidence if they just show in detailed
way how they detect cheaters it's also
tricky I don't really have a clear clear
opinion do you ever play games just for
fun about not recording sometimes not
not that often but sometimes I do is if
there's something specific that gives
you pleasure and shares yeah well I
really I'm really intrigued when
something happens in the game that I
really haven't seen before it doesn't
happen that often if you play for a long
long time yeah but it sometimes still
happen something that's really really
really different or something something
that you have not expected again there's
a question about analyzing owning games
yeah it says he looks through his games
to find a positional pattern right now I
kind of wish I never started to play
bullet at all yeah la playing bullet I
mean really just just do it once in a
while but but don't overdo it there's a
question one was the last time I played
mr. vegas and I've got one on a gas
video coming in the next couple of weeks
I forgot to play the Dutch I forgot to
play the Dodge okay let's do something
else sorry I already forgot to play it
yeah I really cannot say if those guys
in that in that tournament day on
Chester come if they'd she did or not
there were some people who did some
analysis of the games and days
that there were strong evidence that
there was something wrong but this is
really something that is some I mean
this is really something where you have
to know more about computer chess and
this is not just the kind of thing that
I sometimes say it looks like a computer
move or whatever you really if they
achieve in some kind of sophisticated
way it's it's much much more difficult
to to get in to find that out and really
am and to really prove that okay I think
I'm should think about this Bishop them
and probably look for something against
f3 so maybe go here I'll not be five
looks kind of unimportant so this didn't
help so much putting the bishop out
interesting I just wanted something
different so I went for the check benoni
I don't really want to comment on other
platforms who are playing on the ISS see
so it's not that I have many active
ideas do I have any idea I can try to
activate my bishop here maybe I can do
that Bishop d8 up to a five maybe he can
play a five himself was but then I b6
opening up the B file I don't like my
position much something is probably
going wrong but anyway we'll see I think
you should play five without thinking
too much about it I get in Bishop f5 I
think it's slightly helping me at least
yes some someone says in one of the
players who was accused of cheating said
that it was mostly his preparation and
well this happens it really happens
there was one game there was one FM band
and an international master band and the
the international master he he he won
against nakamura in the final round and
when a camera did I mean it's just like
that he played an opening line that is
losing it just straight away losing and
the guy just had to reproduce something
that he knows and in that case I mean
sorry if Nakamura is not knowing that
line he just loses the game and that's
it so one and well it can't happen it
can't happen this is this opening
preparation thing so what am I doing
here before
what a strange position now it's got
before coming maybe I can do this at the
end there's before mm just not a good
position what can you do maybe I can
shoot fire five this is why I'm
canceling you try to get an f5 we are
playing somewhat dodgy openings that you
don't know well can cost can be costly
I'm going to answer a couple of
questions later there are a couple of
things
it sometimes can happen that that you
win out of preparation I mean it happens
it happens I once had a game and this
was pre very long before computer age in
the 90s I played the game and I want in
somewhat below 30 moves with black and
then I i entered it in the in the chest
based database at home and i actually
learned that the whole game just the
final two moves my opponent played two
moves longer than in the original game
but we completely copied a game between
two Grand Master's Russian Grand Masters
completely I mean I I played like it was
a game gardens with white against Dre f
as you remember that so I basically
played like Dre of that game which was
pretty cool um-hmm and it was just a
complete copy and I did not know that
this was theory at all I am I left the I
mean and you would like to move 10 or so
and then it was just a complete rapid
using of things that it can happen I try
for f5 and it takes him some time I
think this position looks dodgy but
maybe it's not that bad his King
position is also slightly shaky so here
we go yes he's six I know all of that
but I have to get counter play so I
allowed that him and have to go from
there let's see what am i doing um I can
can check on age three or just rugby
seven which looks kinda weird taking
there's not helping checking on age
three and Rookie of three that looks
totally wacky but maybe
ah what a strange position yeah yeah
okay so I'm taking their it takes on g6
and unfortunately he threatening 97 then
that's a huge problem how can I should
have played something else that's not
good the 97 idea is especially
problematic wow wow that's bad that's
really really bad what now how do I get
something here this is hanging
everything is hanging the rookie is
singing great great stuff and what I
actually planned is so ridiculous I
cannot even try that okay no no no what
the game on a bad game can I get in rook
f2 or something for okay if I take III
he will play something to have 5 Reds
very simple maybe something to have
seven here rookie have seven then Quincy
aid that full-fledged swindle a mode I
mean I'm just totally busted here hmm I
wonder well it's probably okay what he
did okay I can't give us a check here
with the store no threat him
this is really totally ridiculous pawn
takes Queen G Freud's okay he found that
one that was a bad game ok so now I have
never seen players beating each other
after a game like physically beating
each other there have been stories about
this these kind of things but I never
witnessed it so I was a really really
bad game um I had a question am i
planning to marry soon and difficult no
girlfriend ok that's the question ok the
final one I have to close that broadcast
at some point a different kind of
question if you're trying an opening
over the board that you've never played
in long games before how do you know
that you're ready to play it against
strong opposition how do you get the
confidence when you an uncharted waters
um difficult I mean I think the the
knowledge that other players might have
about openings very often this is
overestimated um and if you if you have
studied things quite well I think you
just you just should just just go for it
I mean playing it out in online chess
and practicing um the the lines is very
helpful so just try to get some
experience under your belt with with
blitz with some some rapid games maybe
and I think just just try it out it's
it's no no other other way to to do it
ok i didn't manage all the questions i
feel it was a pretty busy chad room and
i also played quite badly i hope you
enjoyed some of the games was a bit
rusty i think i didn't play any game
today ended shoulder bit
okay what I also need to mention is that
this is the final broadcast before my
summer break I'm going on and gain going
to to have some vacation and I'm going
to play a little bit of chest as i said
in in poland this will be a quite a long
long time I'm only returning in late
July so i'll be off a couple of weeks
but I definitely let you know when I'm
when I'm back okay so guys I hope you
you liked it and I hope you'll be back
for the continuation of that broadcast
probably July twentieth yeah so we're
talking about five weeks there thanks a
lot for watching bye and bye